on peut parler de deux présidence de
barack obama
les deux premières années de son mandat
où ils pouvaient faire beaucoup de
choses parce qu'il y avait le contrôle
du congrès après les élections mi-mandat
2010 quand j'ai perdu le contrôle du
conflit et où les reculs question lui a
lui refusé énormément de choses qui
étaient dans son programme
ça veut pas dire qu'ils pouvaient rien
faire mais ça veut dire que souvent le
bâtiment quant au bal en devient
président en janvier 2009 le pays vient
de perdre 5 millions d'emplois 800 1000
par mois et il fait adopter par un
congrès qui à ce moment-là lui était
favorable
un plan de stimulation économique de
plus de 800 milliards de dollars de
l'argent emprunté d'ailleurs les
républicains lui pardonneront jamais
mais en même temps on peut dire que
c'est peut-être kirchhoff et les états
unis d'une grande crise économique comme
celle de 1929
on le saura jamais mais bien possible
que ça a été le cas après aujourd'hui
l'économie américaine fonctionne
beaucoup mieux que celle de n'importe
quel pays du jeu probablement que sa
plus grande réalisation ce soit on va
avoir rappelé obama coeur au début
c'était un terme et jarret c'est faux
gamma caméra c'est devenu sa signature
20 millions d'américains de plus pour
l'assurance santé des enfants 26 ans
peuvent rester sur le plan d'assurance
santé globale à et surtout des
conditions préexistantes vous avez du
diabète vous aviez dans haute tension
vous pouviez pas être assurée avant
maintenant que ça reste des voulzy
pourrait changer d'assureur c'est très
important
c'est même tellement populaire que même
si des républiques et maintenant pouvoir
disent 'oh mon dieu on veut s'en
débarrasser le matin surtout glisy dire
maintenant on va le changer parce que
les américains qui n'ont veulent le
garder
en politique étrangère le président
obama avait les coudées plus franches
ils avaient moins de choses à passer au
congrès ça lui a permis par exemple de
réengager des etats-unis dans le monde
de l'environnement avec les accords de
paris avec toutes sortes d'autres
reconnaissances par exemple des
changements climatiques que
l'administration précédente de george
bush ne voulait pas faire
il a aussi signé avec l'iran un accord
de non prolifération nucléaire à l'iran
n'allait avoir la bombe à thônex a été
très contestée aux états unis en
particulier par les l'abbé proche
d'israël mais en même temps beaucoup de
gens n'a pas un peu partout dans le
monde disent que c'était une façon de ne
pas
donner au moyen-orient une espèce de
course à l'armé nucléaire qui aurait
déstabilisé pas mal toute la région et
finalement c'était l'homme de
l'ouverture à cuba il pouvait pas lever
l'embargo contre cuba mais il a mis des
relations diplomatiques entre les deux
pays et a fait que le japon puisse
voyager d'un pays à l'autre
il a largement assoupli le blocus
l'exécution en politique intérieure il
ya beaucoup de choses qui ont changé
pendant des années obama mais pas
toujours à cause du président obama par
exemple le mariage gay est devenue la
règle d'un peu près tous les états
laisser les tribunaux qui ont forcé sur
plus que le président des états unis
par contre on a vu une détérioration des
relations raciales
le premier président droit va pas réussi
à empêcher des mouvements comme la 3d
des manifestations très violentes après
que les loiret futur par des policiers
autant certains le sont par exemple aux
abords témoin en un sens il a essayé
très fort d'obtenir du congrès une
limitation des armes à feu ou au moins
une limitation par exemple les balles
qu'on peut tirer avec eux mêmes armes à
feu après par exemple la tuerie de san
diego dans une école primaire ou
canettes et que c'est peut-être son plus
grand échec
il l'a dit lui même chaque fois qu'une
souris comme ça moi j'allais faire un
grand discours
ça n'a jamais fonctionné au congrès et
car s'il va partir de la maison blanche
parce que c'est ça qui brûle
est ce que dans le train peut défaire ce
que barack obama à faible serait pas mal
plus difficile qu'ils ne le pensent
il ya juste commencé à regarder ou un
make up les distos pire sur cette
affaire là il va certainement de faire
des bouts cela dit il faudra voir parce
que le congrès aux états unis et très
indépendant même si la présidence du
même parti et peut-être qui va décider
où se trament par ce qui lui arrive de
changer d'idée d'en garder
[Musique]